le 8 mai 1945 la victoire des alliés sur
l'allemagne nazie et la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale en europe était
célébrée 68 ans plus tard reste un
important devoir de mémoire et nous
allons donc en parler ce soir avec
gérard coolio pour l'union nationale des
combattants avez vous le sentiment que
le 8 mai 45 signifie encore beaucoup
aujourd'hui pour la plus grande partie
de la population pour les plus jeunes
aussi eh bien j'ai l'impression que
depuis quelques temps il y un renouveau
d'intérêt pour ce i mais car
effectivement c'est une date importante
pour la france avec la victoire sur le
totalitarisme nazi mais un événement je
signerai que mais 45 c'est la victoire
aussi sur les japonais ne faut pas
l'oublier que la guerre s'est poursuivie
en extrême orient après l'europe donc
l'intérêt de tout ça c'est que nous on
essaie de faire venir le maximum de
public de notre concitoyen qui beaucoup
d'ailleurs
ne connaissent pas toujours les la
signification de chaque commémoration
ont pas particulièrement le 8 mai mais
n'importe lesquels et l'important pour
nous c'est d'avoir des enfants des
écoles comme on sollicite pour essayer
de leur montrer un peu le civisme qu'ils
doivent respecter pour
penser que leurs anciens ont combattu
pour qu'ils vivent dans un pays libre et
démocratique comme la france même si
votre sentiment sur le l'atmosphère
actuellement en france on est en période
de crise d'ailleurs pas uniquement en
france il ya toujours un repli sur soi
il est plus difficile d'aller aussi vers
l'autre est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui vous aideront pour le monde
combattant moi j'ai pas l'impression non
on est plutôt maintenant on a la chance
de pouvoir rentrer dans les écoles avant
on ne pouvait pas le faire et c'est
grâce à eux mêmes guigou était ministre
de monsieur mitterrand à l'époque qui
nous a autorisés à rentrer dans les
écoles et la scène pour nous c'est une
grande ouverture séquelles le dire parce
que on est vraiment à l'écouté des
enfants on est près d'eux on leur fait
des causeries débats ce ne sont pas des
conférences on n'est pas pour faire une
histoire on ne remplace pas les profs
d'histoire c'est bien évident mais pour
autant on raconte du vécu de la guerre
c'est qu'on a encore la chance en ce qui
me concerne j'avais 6 ans quand la
guerre a éclaté j'avais 11 ans quand
elle a été punie je me rappelle très
très bien le développement de la guerre
donc on a un vécu que l'on raconte et
les enfants sont captivés aliments se
passe justement les changes avec les
enfants quelles sont les questions
auxquelles vous pose lorsque vous
rapporter des cas une forme dans
laquelle qu'est ce qu'on faisait pendant
la guerre et ce qui est encore l'école
est ce qu'il y avait de la nourriture
parce qu'ils étaient surpris j'ai un
collègue qui est notre délégué de
mémoire pour la région de maisons
laffitte et ça trouve il qui un jour
raconté qu'il ait fait quatre heures de
queue devant l'épicerie pour avoir un
chou-fleur alors là les enfants sont
tombés des nues parce que lisons la
nourriture à profusion il ya du gâchis
de partout et là quand on voit que l'on
fait quatre heures de queue pour avoir
un chou-fleur c'est assez extraordinaire
et pose complètement hors du temps
l'europe aussi est née de la suite de ce
conflit après les traiter les différents
traités de paix aujourd'hui plus que
jamais l'europe est contesté aussi c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut dont il faut
s'émouvoir dont il faut s'inquiéter eh
bien écoutez moi j'imagine qu'au plan
politique c'est possible par contre pl
anciens combattants on essaie d'avoir
des relations d'amitié que l'on fait
d'ailleurs le très précisément aussi
bien avec l'allemagne que l'angleterre
les états unis la belgique les pays les
pays comment dirais je il yougoslavie ce
poste lis tous ces points là donc
nour au point de vue monde combattant on
a plutôt un
l'europe pour nous est plutôt une bonne
chose voilà pour le monde taux atteint
pour le reste maintenant
voir nos politiques ce sont d'autres
d'autres comtés observations
effectivement nous allons marquer juste
une petite pause nous sommes allés à
votre rencontre vous demander si le 8
mai 1945 était suffisamment ou en tout
cas bien commémorer est ce que vous
savez tout simplement aussi ce que
signifie cette date voici vos réponses
et vous pourrez réagir juste ensuite
c'est quoi le 8 mai
commémoration
bouge plus on rappelle non plus c 'est
c'est important de garder quelques dates
on d'ivoire vous voyez le 8 mai qu'est
ce que c'était on se rappelle déjà plus
il ya des gens qui ont un petit peu bavé
1 pour
qu'on en soit arrivé à fêter ce jour là
donc j'estime que c'est
indispensable de continuer même
peut-être d'en parler un peu plus aux
enfants je pense qu'il faut continuer
après on peut peut-être rassembler
plusieurs événements pour les collabos
pour les les fêter ensemble ça ce sera
peut-être une bonne idée ça d'être quand
même d'un certain ton enfin je veux dire
c'est pas que c'est pas un événement
récent donc je trouve qu'on en fait sur
moi je trouve que c'est important de
défaire être garder ce souvenir de
l'ancien de l'ancienne france quoi où
les gens allaient défendre deux pays le
pôle but d'en faire un fast non plus
mais j'estime que ya au moins devoir de
mémoire pour ceux qui sont encore
vivants serait ce que pour eux il ya
beaucoup de choses dans ce micro
trottoir est déjà la première action le
i mais qu'est ce que certaines personnes
ne s'en souviennent même temps
c'est très normal le savez il ya pas
très longtemps j'ai été dans un régiment
et puis j'ai parlé des jeunes militaires
de la guerre d'algérie pour resituer
mathusalem c'était le dernier millénaire
pendillards centenaire donc que lui tu
mec est un peu plus anciens cela
m'étonne pas du tout que certaines
personnes ne se rappellent plus où non
je me suces société mais ça j'espère que
la raison va l'emporter que la force de
faire ces commémorations peut-être que
moi
on peut espérer que le resteront gravés
dans les mémoires faut pas oublier que
lee a pas plus mais il faut aussi penser
à caden 18 il faut penser à tous les
histoires les guerres qui ont fait la
france telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui bon
bien évidemment il faut que le peuple
français que la jeunesse que les nos
concitoyens qui n'ont pas connu la
guerre et surtout nos enfants nous
prennent bien conscience que rien n'est
gagné d'avancé
recevez un totalitarisme peut en cacher
un autre c'est qu'un peu les trains dans
les gares c'est pareil on a chassé les
nazis après il a fallu arrêter le
communisme après c était dans les
balkans et puis et puis et puis il a
partout
dans c'est peut-être le hac lui qu'il
nouvelle qui nous fait des misères ça
fait quelques déclarations d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui pas forcément rassurante
pour la sécurité voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il faut rester je peux dire un mot
pied mais être très vigilant et c'est
pour ça que le monde combattant et très
attentif à cette affaire-là et ne manque
pas de rappeler nos concitoyens la
dangerosité de l'époque et vous serez
présent le 8 mai sur les différentes
commémorations à part des roumains
toutes les villes
par donc vous même vous serez présent
sur paris mais je serai avec eux le prix
modérés public puisque notre président
par un cheikh beau pour notre progrès
national et qui ne m'a délégué ses
pouvoirs donc je vais déposer la gerbe
de l'insee sur la tombe du soldat
inconnu pendant dix-huit voilà quels
sont les autres missions aussi portée
par l'ump qui existe depuis 1918 qui a
été créée au lendemain du premier
conflit toutes affirment été créée par
paire clément sol carrelé victoire et
puis par le bienheureux père brottier
qui était brancardier aux armées il a
été étonné le père brottier de voir des
blessés de guerre les veuves et
orphelins réunir les familles du nord et
qui racontaient leur misère il était ému
parce qu'il n'y avait aucun lien entre
eux sud il faut que je les fédère ces
gens là ils étaient voir que les
manceaux il raconte son histoire ça a dû
être un bon avocat clemenceau lui donner
un nom de cent mille francs or de
l'époque qui venait d'une dame qui avait
perdu son mari et son fils à la guerre
et avec ça il a créé l'ump et le nc est
une jeune fille qui va voir son temps
bientôt 1918 qui se porte très bien il
n'y a pas de problème pour ça et alors
pour revenir à sa mission et à ce devoir
de mémoire cette transmission de ce que
vous avez vécu également puisque par
exemple en ce qui vous concerne vous
étiez présent sur le conflit gérez vous
cette mémoire mais quels sont les autres
missions alors les omissions on a des
commissions multiples et variées on a
d'abord une commission législation qui
ne qui nous permet de défendre les
droits du monde combattant et si
possible d'en acquérir de nouveaux c'est
à dire les retraites les les blessés de
guerre fait tout ce qu'on peut les
tensions enfin tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer est actuellement notre objectif
est d'obtenir la carte du combattant
pour les anciens d'algérie dans les
périodes 62 64 ce sont deux c 19 mars
avec la fin de la guerre officielle mais
qui n'a été respectée que par les
françaises n'est pas par les phalènes à
tel point qu'on a eu 535 morts pour la
france dans cette période là là on
voudrait que la carte de combattant soit
attribuée pour ces périodes là mais on
ne veut pas fermer et monsieur
bouteflika qui entre autres d'ailleurs
vient se faire soigner au fond alors val
de grâce je ne sais pas si vous payez
pas une petite partie de son
hospitalisation d'ailleurs mais bon
cette limitation on a également une
action civique on a tous les ans on a un
thème pour le congrès qui nous permet de
réfléchir sur comment dirais-je le
devenir de la france et dans le monde
combattant et cette année le thème c'est
la mémoire de la france une force pour
son avenir n'en voyons pas de mémoire
les problèmes on à l'action sociale tout
ceci est très important puisque une des
vocations du père brottier de le
clemenceau était de venir au secours des
blessés de guerre des orphelins et des
veuves et tutti quanti alors là par
exemple on a distribué comme 135 mille
euros au niveau national un débile des
demandes de secours de nos adhérents et
rien pour les yvelines on a dépensé très
précisément 21 1873 euros pour les
départements des yvelines uniquement
vous voyez que qui s'ajoutent aux
cinquante cinq mille autres actions
c'est l'action humanitaire voilà je
préside l'action de la commission
nationale qui vient en aide aux
tirailleurs ancien tirailleur africain a
mais française le temps de les décoller
cet avis d'un mot mais il doit prononcer
quand même et
évidemment là on a créé depuis 90 ont ce
dispensaire dans huit pays d'afrique
noire différents et là on envoie des
médicaments
appareils médicaux paramédicaux
ambulances ont fait tout ce qu'on peut
imaginer énormément de mission
j'imagine les abordé lors du prochain
congrès ce sera à cherbourg le 10 mai
juste très brièvement il nous reste
assez peu de temps ce congrès à
cherbourg qui se déroule à partir du 10
mai va servir à quoi mais il va servir à
rassembler le maximum de personnes les
demandes de l'umc de toute la france qui
viennent on aura des multitudes de
cartes qui vont venir on va être environ
entre mettons entre 2000 et 3000
personnes ça dépend
des congrès et là on va faire pour on va
pouvoir faire j'y mets globale de
l'action de l'huile c'est pendant
l'année et avec des objectifs pour
l'année qui vient c'est évident merci
gérard collet au vice président de
l'union nationale des combattants
responsable de la délégation des
yvelines également et vous serez présent
à demain aux côtés du président de la
république pour cette cérémonie du 8 mai
1945 qui commémore la fin de cette
seconde guerre mondiale merci à vous